[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport genannte von mir ein
wichtiger tag bei unseren nachbarn
frankreich hat die wahl im rennen um die
präsidentschaft zeichnet sich ein duell
ab zwischen amtsinhaber makro und der
rechtspopulistin le pen
immer neue massengräber die ukraine
spricht inzwischen von mehr als 1200
toten in der region kiew
flagge zeigen für russland in mehreren
deutschen städten gehen pro russische
demonstranten auf die straße
[Musik]
frankreich wählt und europa bank denn es
ist nicht mehr auszuschließen dass am
ende die rechtspopulistin marine le pen
gewinnt der klare umfrage vorsprung von
präsident makro bis deutlich geschrumpft
heute können die wähler zwischen 12
kandidatinnen und kandidaten entscheiden
deren politisches spektrum reicht von
ganz links bis ganz rechts die beiden
mit den meisten stimmen kommen dann in
die stichwahl in zwei wochen favoriten
sind makro und le pen aus paris an ahnt
er tritt an für eine zweite amtszeit
frankreichs präsident manual marco will
das land weiter reformieren setzt sich
für ein starkes europa ein in umfragen
lag er zuletzt vorn doch nur knapp wegen
des ukraine krieg hat er kaum wahlkampf
geführt
es war eine besondere kampagne sie war
sehr kurz der präsident ist erst spät
eingestiegen und ich glaube die leute
warten ab bis zur stichwahl
wir sind alle etwas verloren mit dem
angebot aber wir müssen wählen
enthaltung ist keine option
dennoch bis zum nachmittag fiel die
beteiligung um vier prozentpunkte
geringer aus als bei der letzten wahl
das könnte den radikalen kandidaten zu
gute kommen deren wähler als besonders
engagiert gelten
so holte markus stärkste herausforderung
marine le pen in den umfragen immer mehr
auf die rechtspopulistin setzt auf die
stimmen der unzufriedenen auf soziale
themen wie wohnen und arbeit wobei sie
franzosen vor rechte einräumen will sie
steht für einen euro skeptischen kurs
ebenso wie der kandidat vom radikal
linken rand jean luc mélenchon sein
programm mehr mindestlohn rente schon ab
60 und austritt aus der nato er wird auf
platz 3 gesehen doch deutlich hinter
lippen und makro die extrem rechte ist
im moment sehr stark in frankreich ich
werde alles daran setzen dass sie nicht
durchkommt es gibt viele viele leute die
in der stichwahl marine le pen werden
würden um nicht markant zu wählen mit
bardot thema crew die entscheidung wer
frankreich künftig führen soll ist auch
eine entscheidung über die zukunft
europas
herr thomas walde in paris was sind die
ersten tendenzen und was steht auf dem
spiel
also dass die wahlbeteiligung in diesem
jahr niedriger ist als vor fünf jahren
und auch vor zehn jahren bestätigt im
grunde den eindruck den man vor der wahl
hatte dass es einen enthusiasmus problem
gibt dass einige kandidaten ein
mobilisierungsproblem haben
überdurchschnittlich war die
wahlbeteiligung demnach heute etwa im
wahlkreis von marine le pen
unterdurchschnittlich war sie hier in
paris was gemeinhin als hochburg emanuel
macros gilt daraus kann man jetzt noch
keinen landesweiten trend ablesen aber
es zeigt das kann heute abend eine sehr
enge geschichte werden ein sehr knappes
ergebnis werden das kann auch in den
kommenden zwei wochen bis zur stichwahl
noch sehr knapp werden und wegen der
doch sehr unterschiedlichen positionen
der hauptkandidaten hier bei diesem
präsidentschaft zu rennen mache das
einmal mehr deutlich dass es nicht nur
für frankreich um sehr viel geht sondern
auch für die deutsch französischen
beziehungen für den zusammenhalt in der
europäischen union und auch in der nato
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
paris thomas weiterer das
jetzt zum krieg in einem telefonat mit
dem bundeskanzler hat der ukrainische
präsident zellen ski die verfolgung der
kriegsverbrechen und weitere sanktionen
gefordert bei kiew wurden neue
massengräber entdeckt in der ost ukraine
versuchen sich die menschen auf eine
weitere russische offensive
vorzubereiten
der freie journalist und ginzel ist dort
unterwegs sein bericht erreicht uns aus
der stadt
wir sind unterwegs von reaktiv richtung
osten richtung front wir wollen das
letzte krankenhaus auf ukrainischem
gebiet besuchen direkt davor ist eine
rakete eingeschlagen
als wir mit den dreharbeiten beginnen
wollen gibt es luft alarm
wir müssen raus aus dem ort von zwei
soldaten die habens haus geholt aus der
klinik es wurden chats gesehen haben am
himmel russische
wir fahren in ein wohnviertel hier ist
vor einer woche eine russische granate
eingeschlagen es war die wohnung von
wladimir trikot er lebt jetzt mit seinen
nachbarn im keller
draußen die sonne seinem gehen wenn man
permanent beschossen wird natürlich habe
ich angst meine ehefrau bistums leben
gekommen
heute morgen ist seine frau im
krankenhaus gestorben erzählt er uns
gestorben an den verletzungen die sie
beim angriff auf ihre wohnung erlitten
hat
der ort ist immer noch umkämpft
zwischen ukraine und russen
wir fahren nach archiv zum krankenhaus
in dem seine frau gestorben ist sind
verabredet mit dem sohn er wünscht sich
dass der krieg endlich aufhört
verteuert der krieg hat schon so vielen
menschen das leben gekostet auch das
leben meiner mama den menschen den ich
am meisten geliebt habe
nur ein schicksal von tausenden in
diesem krieg gegen die zivilbevölkerung
trotz dieser grausamkeit und trotz all
der kriegsverbrechen gab es heute wieder
in mehreren deutschen städten
pro-russische kundgebungen und
autokorsos unter strengen auflagen und
oft begleitet von gegendemos aus
hannover christina eglseder es sind etwa
650 russischsprachige menschen die sich
am mittag in hannover versammelt um
gegen eine angebliche diskriminierung zu
demonstrieren wir sind nicht hier um
über den krieg zu sprechen und für die
medien möchte ich das selber noch mal
sagen dass unser thema heute nicht der
krieg ist sondern die diskriminierung
die uns gegenüber hier in deutschland
wieder fährt und das schon seit mehreren
jahren und erst recht seit kurzem ein
vorwand sagen experten vielmehr gehe es
darum sympathien für den russischen
angriffskrieg kundzutun
etwa jeder fünfte der hier lebenden
russischsprachigen menschen ist laut
studien empfänglich für die propaganda
aus moskau
das ist eine minderheit der großen
russischsprachigen gruppe in deutschland
eine kleine minderheit aber eine
sichtbare und aktive minderheit da wird
das der erzählung putins gefolgt es gebe
keinen krieg in der ukraine es gebe
keine verbrechen an den zivilisten die
polizei angewiesen konsequent vorzugehen
gegen verbotene fahnen oder das zeigen
des sexsymbols
wir geben allen die freiheit sich zu
äußern ihre meinung zu äußern solange
sie nicht den freiheiten anderer
eingreifen beziehungsweise gegen
strafgesetze verstoßen zeitgleich zum
prorussischen autokorso mehrere
gegendemos dreieinhalb tausend menschen
die ein zeichen setzen wollen für die
ukraine wir werden uns auch gegen diesen
autokorso der sehr leicht als
unterstützung des angriffskriegs
gewertet werden kann die blau gelben
fahnen heute in hannover jedenfalls
deutlich in der mehrheit
cdu-chef märz fordert die entlassung von
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel als
rheinland-pfälzische umweltministerin
hatte sie zehn tage nach der
flutkatastrophe im aartal einen
vierwöchigen urlaub angetreten es
beweise sich erneut dass für frau
spiegel urlaub und das eigene image
wichtiger gewesen sein als das schicksal
der menschen an der ahr schrieb märz auf
twitter
vor 77 jahren wurde das
konzentrationslager buchenwald von der
us-armee befreit unterstützt von
aufständischen häftlingen an der
gedenkveranstaltung nahmen erstmals seit
beginn der korona pandemie auch wieder
kz-überlebende teil unter ihnen
anastasia dollar aus der ukraine die 96
jährige ist nach dem russischen angriff
nach deutschland geflohen
die taz zitiert sie mit den worten ich
habe hitler überlebt und stalin ich
werde auch putin überleben
durchschnitt jetzt noch wird sport zur
formel1 schale claire gewinnt den großen
preis von australien ein souveräner
start ziel sieg des ferrari-piloten
weltmeister max verstappen dagegen
schied wegen eines technischen defekts
aus ja und auch kein guter tag für
sebastian vettel
gerät auf einen randstein beschleunigt
dann bricht das heck aus beim einschlag
teils sein kopf richtung lenkrad enorme
kräfte wirken eine medizinische
untersuchung ist die folge ja so weit
gut ich glaube wenn der anschlag heftig
15 geht dann geht ein lämpchen und dann
gehört das zur motive mit schumacher
wird dreizehnter auch durch dieses
wichtige manöver überholt seinen
teamkollegen kevin magnussen für schale
claire rechts ist es ein start ziel sieg
von beginn an hat er die nase vorn auch
beim neustart nach einer safety car
phase wird er den angriff des
weltmeisters max verstappen im red bull
ab wenig später muss der niederländer
mit einer defekten benzinleitung am red
bull aufgeben lewis hamilton wird
vierter hadert mit reifen und motor
sergio perez links im red bull genauso
vor ihm wie teamkollege george russel
schale claire gewinnt sein zweites
saisonrennen
im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga trennten sich bochum
und leverkusen 0 0 bayer bleibt
tabellendritter der vfl 1 runter auf
platz zwölf jessica von bredow wandel
hat gestern abend erstmals in ihrer
erfolgskarriere den dressur weltcup
gewonnen beim letzten großen turnier vor
ihrer babypause siegte die
doppel-olympiasiegerin in leipzig mit
ihrer stute dilara und letzter
gemeinsamer auftritt von dieser bildet
mit weil gold die 17 jährige ausnahme
stute verabschiedet sich in den
ruhestand zum abschied rang drei für das
erfolgsduo
das wars vom schwarz sehr schön
dankeschön galt das wetter bringt sonne
und wärme im nordosten ein mix aus
wolken und etwas sonne sonst überwiegt
der sonnenschein im norden und osten 8
bis 14 im westen und süden 14 bis 19
grad
bettina schausten hat um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal schon zahlen aus
frankreich wir sagen tschüss bis morgen
wünschen ihnen einen guten start in die
neue woche und geben ab zu theo koll und
berlin direkt vielen dank für euer weg
die ukraine spricht heute von
mittlerweile
5600 mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrechen was
heißt das für den künftigen umgang mit
putin und was heißt das für die leise
tretende deutsche außenpolitik und damit
herzlich willkommen bei berlin direkt